the eat and listen at the same time and
that we have two representatives from
the session this afternoon we are going
to prevent present each about 15 minutes
or overview but the sessions this
afternoon are called the first one is
human evolution where have you been and
where we going in the second one is
called human biology the great year we
don't know and how to discover it I wear
their textbook or cell biology every
five years and unfortunately text books
tend to give students the idea that we
may about ninety-five percent of what we
need to know because we don't talk
enough about what we don't know but in
fact we're here to assure especially the
students that there's a huge amount yet
to learn I like to say we probably know
five percent of what we need to know
about ninety-five percent and these two
kinds will first of all talk about
amazing amount we've run in the last 30
years or so but also emphasized where
we're going in what we need to know so
big melon I was going to start and as
you say you have in the program the bios
of all the speakers say I don't need to
waste time going through them great
it's a pleasure to be here thank you all
for coming now um you know there's been
a lot of talk today about the genomics
revolution and it really is a truly
exciting revolution in science that's
going on right now in fact it is so
incredible that I have to use a
soundtrack for my first slide and it's
actually they're going to be some words
in English coming across the screen that
send a little bit of message that go
along with these children of tomorrow
that you'll see developing in the
background I'm going to have to ask for
the lights to be dimmed the will I think
for this in order for you to be able to
see the slides but here goes it's going
to speak for itself
Oh
okay so those are the children of
tomorrow little lab embryos developing
and as you are watching them what you
saw in green was a jellyfish protein
that they're expressing at all the tight
junctions of their hypodermis cells so
you can actually watch the developmental
program unfold inside of these embryos a
process that goes on in the soil all
over this world and a process that has
been going on unbroken through time for
billions of years because as that slide
said the every organism will alive today
including you and me are related to to
each other those worms are related to an
ancestral organism that shared its
ancestry with humans and of course
you're the second speaker today is going
to talk about human evolution a little
bit more specifically but when you think
about human evolution you're often
thinking about chimpanzees and maybe
Neanderthals and then humans in fact I'm
my task is to give you a little bit of a
an overview of the other ninety-nine
point nine percent of evolution and so
I'm going to do that in a few slides
just to make you keep in mind that we
are very closely related to worms and
indeed as Nietzsche said much of what is
in you is still worm so the two themes
that Bruce mentioned a moment ago where
have we been and where are we going and
then the great deal we don't know and
how to discover it and here in this
first slide is a beautiful picture of a
C elegans ovary producing embryos and
you can see on the top several of these
nuclei with their little orange spheres
surrounding them those are germ granules
inside the dark circles that's where the
DNA is that's the genome
and in these little circles around the
outside there are proteins and RNA that
play a very important role in
programming the genome their epigenetic
factors that I'll tell you a little bit
more about in a brief discussion towards
the end of the talk but the important
thing to remember is that all life is
very closely related to each other on
this planet and indeed an ancestral I
think it's in verses book I read
somewhere a very nice quote I don't know
it comes from but at some point in the
history our own German when he had
resided in an ovary very much like this
together with these ancestors of the of
the nematode C elegans and here's the
real Nobel Prize winner the worm C
elegans along with many other model
systems whether it be bacterial cells
yeast flies many important discoveries
with relevance to medicine and direct
relevance to human development have come
from studying model systems and why is
that okay well I often find myself
having to justify you know why would
anyone work on a worm at a medical
school you know you would think you know
you'd work on cancer or liver disease or
something more directly applicable but
in fact as I said we're very closely
related to these organisms and I think
we don't really appreciate how
incredibly closely related we are so I
want to just show you this slide which
indicates on this side a picture like
was on the cover of nature of several
years ago showing a snowball earth event
this is an event that has occurred
several times in the history of the
planet and the most recent of these
events which is a worldwide glaciation
event occurred just just too
little uh before what was Darwin
remarked on as the Cambrian explosion
this explosion of multicellular life
that was larger and for the first time
left a plethora of hard body parts that
became fossilized and the point is that
and this is one of the amazing things
that the molecular biology revolution
has helped us to understand and
appreciate the organisms that live below
that glaciation event were already
incredibly sophisticated organisms like
C elegans and humans they had muscles
they had nervous systems they had eyes
they had sensory organisms of a whole
variety of kinds and they also had the
inner workings the molecular mechanisms
that we know of today the genetic code
is incredibly ancient for example you
heard about the DNA but I think this was
certainly not a given at the beginning
of the market the molecular revolution
when Watson and Crick first described
the structure of DNA there was no
guarantee that everything today would
have the same genetic code but they do
so the ancestors of worms and humans are
back here probably over a billion years
ago there was another fauna that
flourished on the planet called the
Ediacaran fauna that was went through an
extinction coincident with another major
glaciation and then finally we had the
Cambrian explosion the earth warmed
environments became a minimal to life of
larger size oxygen evolved into the
atmosphere and so we had this
flourishing of life so much of what we
think of as progress in evolution is
really the adaptation of these really
incredibly sophisticated highly evolved
creatures that had already survived for
more than three quarters of the history
of life prior to the Cambrian okay and
I'm going to mention something today
just a little bit about this thing
call Arnie I which I work on which is a
genetic mechanism that exists in plants
and animals and fungi and even some
bacteria that allows the organism to
control genetic information even after
its left the nucleus but the thing that
I want to bring out here just briefly is
the point that life is ancient on this
planet and indeed if the environment
were to continue to be supportive to
life life is immortal this is this is
truly amazing and one of the motivations
for me as a scientist when I was a young
kid was this idea that life can span
these incredible periods of time and I
don't think we can really appreciate
this when I was here with Andrew fire in
2006 we shared with rise the stage with
George consoles me and Tom matter whose
work helped map the cosmic background
radiation in in David to age of the
universe about 13.7 billion years we are
remarkable together about was that life
exists on that causing time scale
likewise on this planet rose 3.8 billion
years ago that's older the same scars as
we get to be and it's a it's actually
close to our order to age movers more
than more than reporter if you want to
look at out of the night the night sky
this is a decision shuttle Hubble tell
Stella special show you here's the
visiting Dipper and there's no story
place you see I wanted water there
that's because know when you're here and
then anomalous where that is going in
here here and the imagine came that
showed us and where you point at all
schools that sky or did away from stars
that are now Chauncey and you run look
take a long exposure over you see a
field
yes and those are not stars every one of
those two galaxies with an average
number of stars so the universe as
ancient as it is is also incredibly vast
in an every direction that we look there
are more and more galaxies undoubtedly
the universe is teeming with life and I
think it's just important for all of us
you know thinking about where we've come
from we've all come from this amazingly
mysterious universe that we inhabit and
that's one of the beauties of science
that it brings us into a more mysterious
world not a less mysterious world now
briefly I don't have time to give a
seminar about my work but I want to just
tell you something that we're very
excited about mainly because I think one
of the questions in to me that's very
important and I think very motivational
is what do not know and how do we
discover it really one of the themes and
in order to learn something when you
don't even have a hypothesis yet you
really have to step back and let the
organism tell you what is important and
in order to do that kind of experimental
work you need to use model organisms
model organisms play a very important
role in the kind of genomics and
genetics that Eric Lander talked about
today although he didn't really mention
it there sort of the glue that pulls it
all together for us because you identify
a disease gene in the human now you have
to try to understand how that disease
gene functions in the cell in order to
study that in human would take lifetimes
decades and we don't have that kind of
time so instead we turn to a model
animal for example like C elegans where
you can model many of the cellular
pathways that are important in cancer
and a whole variety of other pathways so
one of the things my lab has been
fundamentally interested in is
how to cells process information and I'm
going to talk in my last few minutes
here about this question can cells
remember is there is there and they
clearly do but in this case I mean can
they actually experience something new
and then take that acquired information
and pass it on to their progeny and in
fact they can we call that epigenetics
um and what I'm showing you in this
picture are three different pictures of
proteins we call Argonauts which are
I'll show you in a moment factors
involved in epigenetics and you can see
that they form these red or green
speckles around the nucleus the DNA is
staying in blue and you're looking at
many nuclei in that ovary of the worm
and you're seeing these granular
structures on the Opera of the germ
cells similar structures also exists in
the human and in fact in all animals now
before I this movie is just going to
show you everything you need to know
about molecular biology and the cell in
one minute this is the DNA we're flying
along here in a spaceship and you can
see the DNA now opening up to be
replicated actually this is to be
transcribed into RNA and this is the RNA
polymerase the big green blob here that
this is not an actual cell in fact if it
was an actual cell say a little bit more
on this in a moment these events would
be occurring of much much faster this is
splicing that RNA is being now Polly
adenylate adana transported out into the
cytoplasm once in recite applause and
it's going to be translated by this
amazing machine called the ribosome the
ribosome there is tracking along reading
the triplet code incorporating amino
acids
and in a moment you're going to see a
scientist injecting double-stranded RNA
that should have been a helical but they
made a mistake there let's die sir okay
dicing it up into little pieces now the
one strand is taken away and the other
strand carries information the scientist
is now using the cells search engine to
find target sequences and to regulate
them and that's the RNA interference
mechanism now I'm just going to say a
couple more words on but the key thing
here is that the cell has a way of
regulating information after it leaves
the nucleus and why is that okay the
cell is completely full of information
cells entered the information age 3.8
billion years ago okay lucky us we that
is us biologists we entered the
information age just in time for the
genome revolution because without the
technology the process information
ourselves we would be helpless we
wouldn't be able to the genome sequence
would be completely useless without some
way of analyzing it rapidly now inside
the cell we leave it or not that little
green thing that that transcribed RNA at
a rate of 50 / 50 residues per second
per second and almost flawlessly the
ribosome translates that genetic code at
three codons or three nucleotides per
code on at the rate of 20 codons per
second imagine the information flowing
in that cell and once that RNA is out in
the cytoplasm it's being translated that
fast making protein that is telling the
cell do this do this do this the cells
on a track right it needs a way to
change track to change directions
quickly it can't wait for the gene to
turn off and the RNA to degrade it's got
to have a way of controlling that
information once it's out there and so
cells invented these Argonaut proteins
and I'm going to
we discovered our DD 1 which is the
first of these Argonaut proteins
involved in the mechanism you were just
watching it's a cellular search engine
but one of the great things about
genomics is when you clone a one-gene
like re 1 which we cloned in a genetic
screen for mutants that knock out an RNA
interference response you find all the
homologs of that gene in the genome
including over here for human genes
these HS a go one through four and four
more human genes over here and what you
see right away is that are you one is
actually less similar to the human genes
here then to other genes in the worm and
in fact the worm has not just one of
these Argonaut proteins it has over 20
of them and the human has eight who's
for over there and there's four over
there there's two worm jeans over here
on this side in the circle you can see
one of them that are related to those
four they are involved in the germline
in the human and the mouse where they've
been studied and of course I'm not going
to have time to go into all this but the
point is genomics empowers model systems
in a way that is you know really
transformational because when you
identify a gene in a model system you
can now instantly find the gene in the
human genome and you can begin to learn
about how the human works so we
discovered an RNA interference mechanism
a mechanism in the worm immediately
thereafter we were able other
researchers will be able to begin
translating that into applications in
the human and indeed what they found
I've been told google is streaming this
right now so I'm not just putting this
up as a plug for google but this enzyme
is in fact the search engine of the cell
it allows the cell to take a short piece
of genetic code and to use that
information to rapidly search for and
control related information throughout
the cell
importantly in 2001 or 2002 shortly
after the genome sequence was almost
complete we again speaking for the field
began to use or understand how to use
the RDI method to introduce our own
search queries into the human Google if
you will so in culture it's actually
very straight forward now to order by
Federal Express a sequence that will
turn off any human gene and it will be
here tomorrow and it's guaranteed to
turn your gene off or your money back
okay not your gene but the gene in your
cell in the laboratory and in fact you
this really has become a very important
tool for research because now we can
very rapidly profile genes that are
expressed or perhaps miss Express in a
diseased state and we can inactivate
those jeans very easily very rapidly in
the laboratory and begin to discover
their functions and what this enzyme
does is it holds a short piece of RNA
here in red that's the guide strand it
uses that genetic information to make
base pairs with target sequences and
then it wraps the red strand wraps
around the target and there's a
catalytic Center pushing the target blue
strand up into this catalytic center
allowing that protein to cleave the
target and stopping the activity of that
that RNA even after it's been expressed
so cells enter the information age
billions of years ago they've been
regulating the information in this kind
of way for a really long time and
they're very very sophisticated they're
on operating system like three billion
at this point literally it's really
exciting so I really don't have time to
go into it but you know I'm talking
about the most high
the evolved organism here on the planet
the nematode worm C elegans okay this
this little animal can make 300 progeny
in three days and it doesn't even have
to find a mate it's basically incredible
incredible animal and it can what we've
discovered recently is that it is using
Argonaut systems to remember what genes
it expressed in the last generation and
what you see again this is just the same
picture but indeed these three different
Argonauts represent these are the search
engines represent different mechanisms
in the cell one is a memory of non-self
the Wego pathway those that is a memory
of which genes to keep off next
generation Cesar one we believe we're
about to test this I hope is a memory of
self it remembers which genes to turn on
and allow to be expressed each
generation and the prg one argonaut
family the peewee Argonaut is a search
engine that finds things that have not
been seen before and I'm just going to
show you the model that we're working on
now we're genomically encoded short RNA
is called peewee RNAs are loaded on to
this Argonaut called peewee it can
search not for naught not for viruses or
for some weird structure associated with
bio RNA that it can actually look for
sequences that have not been seen the
before and the way it does that is by
communicating with these two different
memory systems if it has been seen
before the caesar system prevents the
skin factor from initiating the
silencing pathway and then once the
silencing pathway is initiated it's
maintained permanently and this is not
soft epigenetics this is hard
epigenetics this is permanent silencing
of a gene and its really i'm going to
just skip ahead because i don't want to
take up too much time but we actually
gave this a new a new name RNA induced
epigenetics because
as the way it works is a gene can enter
one of two states when it's introduced
into the cell so we call this putting a
transgene in on the left-hand side you
have a transgene that's turned off and
on the right-hand side you have a new
transgene that's turned on and the
interesting thing is that they interact
with each other so the silent allele can
actually send an RNA signal that turns
off the active allele inducing an
epigenetic silent state that is
maintained permanently in the animal
interestingly there's also an activating
signal the active allele can transmit an
activating signal after enough in this
again is still not proven but we believe
that this licensing state becomes fully
licensed over time once a gene is fully
licensed for expression in the animal it
can trans activate a silent allele so
initially silencing is dominant you get
dominant silencing eventually activation
is dominant and I bring all this up only
because you know this is a worm and
surely humans can't work this way you
know this is this is a really
sophisticated stuff maybe maybe worms
are special they've said that before
about worms and I think they are special
actually but that doesn't mean humans
aren't special too and I'll end here by
talking just a moment about the future
where we're going this is my daughter
Ricki back in 2006 she's here tonight
today and you can see here at the Nobel
Prize headquarter where you know there's
gold medals everywhere you know it's
amazing just down the street if you ever
get a chance you should go there and of
course when we went in I said Vicki grab
as many of those as you can so you can
see her picking them up and sticking
them in her shirt and stuff and the
reason these go
metals are really special of course is
that they're filled the chocolate and
the reason this slide is very poignant
is that ever since vicki was about one
and a half she's had type 1 diabetes so
for hurry eat that chocolate she has to
give herself insulin the implement she
takes is made for her by bacteria that
read the human genetic code and make
human insulin for her and for millions
of other people like her without it she
would die and that is the kind of
medicine that is the kind of
transformational medicine that we
collectively as assigned to the
community our daily on the verge of
discovering the genome project has
accelerated those opportunities
unfortunately funding is not keeping up
we need our people you folks to vote to
get your governments to spend more
because there are tremendous tremendous
opportunities to change and to save
lives of people like Vicki who now
suffer for many diseases as Eric Lander
pointed out we now know the genetic
underlying cause of many diseases but
getting a treatment can take years we
need to step up the funding not flat
fund science as we have been doing in
the United States I hope not in Sweden
and I'll stop there and I don't know if
we have time for questions Bruce no okay
thank you very much
okay so we'll change gear a little bit
to more recent evolution and perhaps I
should start out by saying that I think
that one of the very many unexpected i
think consequences of the elucidation of
the DNA structure that was honored here
50 years ago its extent to which the
study of genomes of DNA sequences from
organisms have illuminated evolutionary
history in general and what I will dwell
on then human history in particular and
in hindsight that may not be that
surprising perhaps given the fact the
slides are actually bigger than the
screen they would cut off here but given
the fact that our genome is 3.2 billion
nucleotides or letters big and each of
us of course carried to gino's one from
our moms and one from our dads and the
number of differences between these two
gino's is in the order of 3 million or
so and these differences between a
genome in million one of you go back to
mutations and happen in our ancestors so
by looking at the patterns with which we
share these mutations we can find out
things about what happened in the past
and one of the most fundamental things I
think that have come out when one study
this variation in humans is that most of
our genetic variation exists in Africa
so we take the variation in Africa and
compare it to the variation outside
Africa although there is probably seven
or eight times more people living
outside Africa the amount of genetic
variation there is less and all those
variants that we find outside of Africa
most of them we find related variants
inside africa but in addition we find
the compol
the variation in Africa that's not
outside and the interpretation that has
come out of that is that the origin of
our direct ancestors of fully modern
humans that are essentially as us is in
Africa and that some of that variation
went out so to say to colonize the rest
of the world and we've been also able to
get an approximately date on that by
looking at for example the extent to
which these mutations are associated
with each other along a chromosome and
one has found out that that date is
quite recent so in the order of say a
hundred thousand years ago people start
coming out of Africa and more seriously
about 50,000 years ago so what I then
often like to say that from a genomic
perspective with real in African species
we were spacious that emerged in Africa
quite recently and either we still live
in Africa or we're even live in raw the
recent ex I outside Africa but there is
of course a complication of this model
and that is that when modern humans
appeared hundred thousand years ago or
so they were not alone on the planet
there were other forms of humans around
both inside africa and outside Africa
for example in Europe although you don't
really see us on the slide they were
well known Neanderthals and further to
the east there were other forms and a
big big debate since 30 years or so in
paleontology is what happened when
modern you must met these forms did one
mix or not for example and such
questions we can now also address where
genomic means so my laboratory work
since almost 30 years now on methods to
retrieve DNA from old bones like this at
our 30 40 50 thousand years old we've
done this from sites such as these in
Croatia where you find Neanderthals you
can now
drill a little hole in a bowl take out
some bone powder and retrieve DNA from
it and study the entire genome and what
has come out of that over the past two
years is the insight that indeed when
modern humans came out of Africa and
very early humans that became the
ancestors action of everybody outside
Africa they somewhere perhaps in the
Middle East met Neanderthals mixed with
them and then carried a bit of
Neanderthal DNA with them to other parts
of the world to the extent that in the
order of two to three percent of the
genome of people outside Africa come
from now because also gone on to study
other extinct forms of humans further to
the east a cleaner place called the
nests of a cave where in 2008 Russian
archaeologists found a tiny little piece
of a finger bone from the last digits of
a pinkie and our techniques are now so
efficient in retrieving DNA from such
remains that from this little piece of
bone we've been able to determine a DNA
sequence that is as accurate of the
whole genome as we would do from a blood
sample from one of you today and we have
then been able to show that this little
pinky comes from a group of humans be
called the missiles that are related to
knit Neanderthals but have a long
independent history when it also been
able to show that they have contributed
to people today but not in Siberia out
there where they won't found this bowl
but in melanesia so in Papua New Guinea
and Australia in Fiji and so on so this
sort of model that were to explain this
is that when modern humans come to
Southeast Asia they carry with them the
Neanderthal component they need the NISS
alone somewhere mix with them and go on
out into the melanesia carrying with
them now in addition the Dennis of a
component to the extent them that
there is five percent of the New Zealand
DNA for example in people in Papua New
Guinea so sort of our view that has come
out of this then of what happened when
modern humans appear in Africa we don't
know quite where but then emerged out of
Africa is that amidst Neanderthals and
at least once maybe two times at least
makes me on the tall's continue to
spread over the world somewhere in
Southeast Asia they will meet the new
servants mix with them and continue out
to part two melanesia that we have time
this other forms of humans become
extinct probably in some form related to
the parents of modern humans or
extinction but they live on a little bit
today than in that two three four five
percent of the genomes of people today
come from this extinct forms and you can
see the consequences of that if you then
study a genomic variation today an
unfortunate important part of this slide
is sort of cut off but this is a picture
of chromosome 21 in Europeans in many
hundred Europeans and below here it was
compared to the Neandertal genome and
you would have been able to see that
there are three four percent of
Europeans that look almost identical to
Neanderthals for a segment here so there
are so chunks of DNA that we can find in
two three percent of people in this room
that are almost identical to Neanderthal
and what then becomes very interesting
is of course to ask the question well
what does that mean does that mean
anything for our phenotype as we would
say today that is how we look how we
behave our bodies function do these
chunks of genes that come from the
undertones have any consequences and
they reheat really the limit of our
knowledge today there is some
indications that some genes involved in
the immune response have come over from
the undertones and initiatives to us but
we don't know if some variants that came
over has any influence on the sea
susceptibility or on other features in
ourselves I want to come back to this
difficulty in answering questions like
this at the very end but before that I
just want to mention that there is an
other aspect of this work that I find
really interesting and that is that here
we have the human genome in a complete
form not just a part like that we can
compare it to the great apes but now we
then have the genome of our very closest
relative the neanderthals so we're not
let any more comparing our lineage back
5 to 7 million years to common ancestry
with the chimps but we can look over the
last half million years suppress 400,000
years in human history and look on
everything that happened in our last
segment of our history and why is that
particularly interesting when I think
it's interesting because it happened a
lot of things in human history in this
last part that has a big consequence for
our history of course but it's not only
self-interest because much of what
happened to us have now consequences for
large portion of the biosphere actually
with modern humans technologies start
changing rapidly for example
Neanderthals lived from four three four
hundred thousand years and made pretty
much the same stone tools at the
beginning of their history as towards
the end of their history with modern
humans this totally changes and our
technology today is across totally
different from just a few thousand years
ago another aspect is art at least art
that we immediately recognize its art
comes only with fully modern humans and
another aspect is that we start
spreading this earlier forms of humans
lived in Africa Asia Europe for almost
two million years they never spread over
oceans and in just 50 thousand years we
have spread to every habitable part of
the globe and as I said we influence
large part of the biosphere today as we
know so the reasons or was it biological
background for this presumably resides
in something that
changed in our biology in this last
little piece of our history so these
were other mutations that happened on
the way to humans that are fixed in
everybody today no matter where we live
on the planet we share these changes but
the Neanderthals look like the Apes and
the monkeys and since a few months now
since we had this high quality Geno of
adenosine the relative amount at all and
also now actually over Neanderthal we
can make this catalog of all these
changes and the fascinating thing is if
you could see it that is not a very long
list it's around 100,000 changes in our
genome that are present in everybody as
far as we know today and are so recent
that they happen after the Neanderthals
and around 10,000 gains and losses on
Europe you type in the genome so that's
not a very very long list so the
fascinating question I know think is how
can we say what they which are this
hundred thousand changes are of
importance for how we look how we behave
how we think for our cultural
development and here we're now so to
come up towards the limits of our
abilities of our knowledge and
capabilities today one way to sort of
predict what such a change would course
is what Eric disgustingness talk is to
look a gene that is affected by such a
change what diseases do we know that
effect that keen the other mutations in
the gene what disease is to the core
course and this is now hard to follow
here but we have a list of 35 of these
genes that are affected by such things
we know monogenic diseases that affect
them four of these 35 genes affect the
skin let's perhaps not so surprising but
something in our skin looks or functions
a change recently Newman history more
surprising is that six of these genes
actually affect the eye so it's sort of
as a surprise to me at least something
invasion may have changed recent and
human history but what it is we have no
clue of course so another way of going
after this is to look for what is
conserved what is the same in all
monkeys in all Apes and in the under
calls yet have changed in humans very
recently and spread so that we all carry
it so if we look at that way on these
jeans now just focusing on genes that
encode proteins that we understand the
best where 23 genes with such changes
and is rather interesting to note that
two of them effect soon xo nolan
dendritic growth so how nerve cells
establish contacts with each other in
the brain two other ones effect synaptic
transmission how this axons and
dendrites send signals to each other in
the brain and two others of them or
correct area risk alleles for autism
another a disease where at least to some
extent is due to problems the
communication of nerve cells but there
is a bit but on which I want to end this
is interesting it hints on what systems
might be affected but we have no clue
what this change is really cause so sort
of dream for the next decade i think is
to be able to with some chance of being
correct many most of the times come from
a genomic change to predicting what that
has for consequences in a phenotype as
you heard in Eric to Eric's talk most of
this knowledge now comes from going from
the phenotype back to the genome by
looking for association in the
population between diseases and the
genome or linkage in families between
diseases and the genome but the big big
hope the dream is then in the future to
be able to go directly from the genome
and understand something of the
phenotype are looking at it in these
types of changes or in the genome
sequence in a patient
so how would we ever come to that I
think there's a huge questions the big
data has a bass over now that we need to
be collected we need to know in the end
of the day how each gene is regulated in
each cell type in our bodies and then we
need to know how the gene products of
these genes work together in systems if
you like in each cell type and we meet
in the end them to know the function of
each single nucleotide in our genome in
each cell type so that we in a in a way
actually in the end understands how the
genome can produce a human being and
that's of course a very very tall order
a long term goal so to say but perhaps
then after lunch in this discussion
discussion session we can discuss how we
could take the first steps in that
direction and we let then I thank you
for your attention
yeah where you get to go on over the
next Hall cross the street again see you
there bigger size